CONGRESSMAE RASKINWELCOME TOROG
N ON
COMMITTEE BUT THE CLEAR AND OUR
STILPOSES?HE
T EVEN DONALD
TRUMN'
IT ANYMORE.
HET CAME RIG
AND ESSENTIA
EN  HE'S BEENNG ABOUT WHO
N TI.E IDEA
THAT HE'S BEENFF HISFOLLOWERS B
S SOMEHOIN
INTOIOORU KNOW,
ANNGURFI
BASIDEDUCEINPROCESS.HE JUSCOT
DI'TMI WIMP.
WAS JUST CALLINA COWARD.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGEO DOD
MIENO VIOLATING HITITUTION RUNI
HIMSELF WHO SHOULD BE THTE YOU'.
BUT THE COMMITISLENGED AS WE SP
E.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO ADE HAS BEE
THE COMMITTEE IS H
HAND IN DELAYIS OFRYMPESTHOSRRON
R ABTHIS VE I
E S WELL
THE E SELECTE'S FAILE
DEPARTMENT ACCESS TO THESE
TRANPTBOAPPENING ON
RIMINAL CONDUCT ATES THE 'S ABIN
INIA THE JANUARY
AUSE YOU KNOW  OUR
KNOW AS WETHE
COMMITTEE'S WORK IGISLATIVE.
IT'S AT FUNCTION.
THICE HAS
PROSECUTE? THAUE WELL, IIN T SP
THE DEPARTNTE
L THSELECT COMMITTEE ABO  IS TH
TED TOLLY JUSTING SSINTERVIEWS
WHVE TACCESS?N,0
>> OUR LEGAL STAFF ARE INVOLVED
IN ACESSITE
TH TURNING
EVHIHEY HAVE OVER TO UBECAUSE T
PAICLINES AN
STRICTURES.
AND IT'SHE EXACTIT POWERS.
ANTH H E
, INCLUDING THE  POWER.
SO, RE OUR THE PEOPLE.E'RE G
AB TO WORK THINGS OU
F JUST I'MTHE
HAPPEN. FORMEECUTOR, I THINK
TOOSS MY Ts.
IF THERE'S ID TO
PROVIDE, IF IT, AN ITY TO HE TH
RELATIONSHIP COME
BU
PAA BIT AT'S TEALE MMITTEE,ON.
D SAY
INSCSI
REFERRALS. O
I KN YE SPOKEN OUT ABO
WHAT TCA
WHAT DO MA INTERPRET ABO A
PERCDIONERE HASN'T BEEN THE HEAA
HIGHLIGHTED IN EARLIERSTREVIEWOO
>>OUH ONE OF
E HEARNGA
DEVELME LEADING OOKING AT D
UP TO JAY 6.E ATTACK OSTATE LEG
ET NULLIFYHE
POPULAVOTE ANDT INSTALL ECR ABO.
THERE IS THE ATTACK ONHE
ELECTION OFFICIALS.
AND THAT'SIN
PEE SECRETARY OF STATE
O TR
FO INVT TES FOTHHARY TO GET DEPT
NC UTEELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTES C
.OI
TOLD IN DUR THLE OF WEEKS.
AS SY AS POSSIBLE.
>> ARE YOU HAVING DIFFICULTY AT
ALL GETTING THENS WIITNESSES YO?
THERE ARE SOME WE KN H
THUMFAR AS WE OW ABOSSUE.
ARYOY TRYINGL DO WITNESSESE HEA?
ISREG ISSUKNOW PERSO GAVE BIRTHH
CLOSER YOU GET TO DO TO
VECOME ID
COOPERAT N THE VT  O THACOMPR  O
PEOPLE LPETED D MARK MEADOWS
STEVNN WHO SLY THINK BECAUSE TH
KNOWAL
THE LAW.
E
N COURASENTLY AS TWO DAYS AGO,
COLUMBIA REJECTED E
TESH THEICTMENT ANJECTEDF
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL CLAIMS AN
T HOANNL
D WE REALE
ALL OFT'TED REPELY, AND
YET STILR IT FROM P'ANTS AND AC
WHO REALLYCTGH THEY'RE
OV
SO, WE HAVEN'T LET THAST
WE'RE COLLECTING ALL THE IDENCE.
NOW,S S FREEERE.
E EME THE RIGHT TO THE INFORMAT